one of the the greatest moments i've
ever seen in a huddle chuck daly calls a
play and robin goes chuck i think mark
should be in the game right now to run
this play and mark goes no dennis you
can do it
anthony connects from the outside
carmelo anthony with some great work
till that top and put up
ready play from carmelo anthony i give
that about a 9.5 for the deal difficult
one of the top 75 players of all time
carmelo anthony he's a great post-up
player left box right box turn around
shoot and then he can stretch out to the
three-point line and not only did he
have three-point range he had mid-range
he really had the total package he also
had that in college one in college at
syracuse carmilla anthony was everything
that you wanted a basketball player to
be let me tell you about another guy
that reminds me of carmelo anthony his
name is mark o'guard here's aguirre
over gilliam isaiah way up to aguirre
he's all alone here's the bunny slam
aguirre does it again boy a vintage move
mark aguirre and i really live like
three blocks from each other chicago is
legendary for their great players
and during that period of time let me
tell you some of the the nba players who
made it to the pros during that period
of time eddie johnson mark maguire craig
hodges rod higgins doc rivers daryl
walker terry cummings myself that was
the era that we were coming up in mark
mcguire was the man i mean there was
only one player at that time in chicago
and they were talking about mark mcguire
leaving high school playing in the nba
for mark maguire shoot it pass it take
you off the dribble dunk it host you and
just like carmelo anthony took the
nuggets to the western conference finals
mark maguire goes to the dallas
mavericks an expansion team takes them
to the western conference finals playing
against the los angeles lakers tonight
the state of michigan is the basketball
capital of the world
[Applause]
the detroit pistons
back-to-back nba champions when we talk
about mark aguilera and you talk about a
hall of fame career as a champion one of
the greatest moments in the one of the
most unselfish moments that i've ever
seen in a huddle dennis rodman
who's this up-and-coming
superstar hall of famer he's sitting on
a bench and chuck daley calls a play
rodman goes chuck i think mark should be
in the game right now to run this play
and mark goes
no dennis
you can do it
all right listen listen do a marketing
situation no
timeout situation
watching mark aguirre empower dennis
rodman and
not being selfish or
or anything about it it just made us a
great team it allowed ryman to really
flourish
but it also in our mind as his teammates
it let us know the type of champion that
had come to join us anthony to the
basket car
anthony herzeguard getting low and puts
it in the basket anthony connects turn
back the clock dwyer against green gets
help up over the top and he hits it i
think mark aguirre doing my era i think
he was one of the fastest to reach 10
000 points in terms of scoring when you
look at carmelo anthony
and the type of score he became in the
nba and what he can do
from shooting a basketball to putting
the ball in the hole these two eerily
remind me so much of each other in terms
of scoring a basketball and also being
great teammates true champion
look em up future hall of famer mark of
white